my name is PAX haymeyer I'm the director
of credit bearing programs here at the
Stanford center for professional
development and it is my pleasure today
to host Alex Stamos uh from the Stanford
internet Observatory he will be talking
a little bit today about engineering a
safe safer internet or more
fundamentally what is trust and safety
engineering Alex Stamos is a cyber
security expert a business leader and
entrepreneur working to improve the
security and safety of the internet
through his teaching and research at
Stanford University he's the director of
the Stanford internet Observatory at the
Cyber policy Center a part of the
Freeman fogling super international
studies where he's also a research
scholar in addition to his work as a
scholar and a researcher Alex is also a
practitioner and prior to joining
Stanford he served in a variety of
senior roles including as the chief
security officer of Facebook probably a
job no one uh no no one envious him
having as well as the Chief Information
Security Officer at Yahoo so he's
bringing a combination a really unique
combination of the the research and
scholarship as well as as a practitioner
who's actually been in the trenches and
done a lot of this work so Alex with
that I'm just going to hand it off to
you today we're going to be talking
about trust and safety engineering and
focusing on a class that you teach here
at Stanford that is open to remote
students as well as on campus students
and so we we might as well get started
with with the title of this class which
is what is trust and safety engineering
thanks Pax uh really excited to be able
to offer computer science 152 trust and
safety engineering to students who are
not able to come to the Stanford campus
and this could be an exciting hybrid
class for both students on campus and
off uh and ability for working
professionals to to learn about the
space and to collaborate with current
Stanford computer science students but
that's a great question what is trust in
safety so trust and safety is a little
bit of a industry term for the way
studying how people abuse the internet
to cause harm right so the term comes
from the tech industry starting about
maybe 20 years ago it started becoming
Vogue especially with payment companies
auction sites and such
um it is now a much broader set of
looking at all the different ways people
can use these online services to cause
on
usually when you talk about trust and
safety issues you talk about people
using products the way they are designed
to work so this is what distinguishes
trust and safety from information
security or cyber security when you talk
about security you're talking about
people trying to manipulate a system to
make it misbehave to break it right you
hack a system you break a system
we talk about trust and safety people
are using these products in a
technically correct manner but the
outcome of what they are doing means a
human being gets harmed
um and so it is a quite a different
field and a much more interdisciplinary
field than information security which is
much more about computer science and so
while this is a computer science course
and students get computer science credit
from the Stanford CS Department we are
approaching it from much more of a
cross-disciplinary than some of the
other CS classes
part of the reason why is there are
important technical components here
we'll talk about how machine learning
works we'll talk about how to abuse
machine and use machine Learning Systems
we'll talk about cryptography and how
cryptography can protect uh users we'll
talk about a variety of different
technical components and there will be a
technical project but to really do this
work you have to have the technical
skills but you also have to have an
understanding of society and Humanity
that is broader than most uh areas of
computer science
um and one of the things that's really
fascinating about trust and safety that
is a lot like infosec is its Dynamic and
unpredictable this is a situation in
which you're dealing with adversaries uh
and this is one of the reasons I find
both security and trust and safety to be
really intellectually interesting
because in other fields of engineering
your adversary are the laws of nature
and physics it is thinking about if you
want to if you're a civil engineer and
you're building a bridge you're fighting
against corrosion and gravity and
Material Science issues and this is an
area where things just kind of get
better and better and better as we have
a better understanding in the physical
world and the way that Engineers can
build systems that live within those
rules
trust and safety is not like building a
bridge it's more like playing chess you
never are done becoming a great chess
player and you can't become a good chess
player just by reading books about it
you have to practice and that's one of
the things that keeps this a very
interesting field is whatever you do in
it just like with security people will
turn around and react and you have to
get up the next day you can have a great
day A Tuesday you go to bed I did a
really good thing I kicked a bunch of
bad guys off the internet or I got some
bad guys arrested and Wednesday morning
they're doing something totally
different
um and that can be discouraging for some
people but I think it also makes it a
very Dynamic field to be in an
interesting field up the other reason I
think this is a really important area
is uh most of the harm that actually
accrues to people online is not due to
hacking or infosec vulnerabilities it is
due to abuse again the the technically
correct use of these products to cause
harm
um infosec is really only the tip of the
Pyramid of the bad things that happen
for for every kind of high-end hacking
attack that you hear about there are
hundreds or thousands of examples of
people being harassed until they're
offline the people having their photos
stolen intimate photos and distributed
online of children being sexually abused
online that happens at a much larger
scale than the technical stuff we talk
about and even if you dive into the
security field into infosec what you'll
find is the things that are really
hurting people are the much more prosaic
human problems such as the account life
cycle or the difficulty of of patching
in large organizations and so one things
we talk about in this class is the fact
that we spend a huge amount of time
think about the tip tip of this pyramid
of the really sexy new vulnerabilities
and new flaws and we don't spend enough
time in computer science thinking about
the things that happen every day where
people make mistakes with their
passwords where they reuse passwords
where they get their phone number stolen
that actually in some cases has much
more impact
one of the things we also talk about in
this class is the biggest challenges
that's facing this field
by far the biggest scale
when you talk about very large platforms
you're talking about companies that have
something like 50 60 000 people uh but
they're serving two billion three
billion users right so if you're talking
about like the YouTube scale the
metascale
um soon The Tick Tock scale you're
talking about billions of users
um and so figuring out engineering
techniques that allow a relatively small
number of people to keep a large number
of people safe is one of the key issues
here another issue is that we
traditionally have not had a diverse set
of people in this field a lot of people
that move into trusted safety come from
the places where these companies are
headquarters like California or the
United States overall but when you talk
about three billion users obviously the
vast vast majority of them are not
American are not English-speaking and
the kinds of issues they face sometimes
are quite different and that's one of
our goals with the class and in the
field overall is to try to diversify the
set of people that work in it so that we
can have more diverse studies of abuse
and more diverse Solutions there's a lot
of measurement and definitional
challenges we talk about what is hate
speech is something that you can spend
years thinking about and trying to kind
of philosophically Define
um and yet you don't have years to do
that if you go and work with these
companies you have to come up with a
definition and then you have to be able
to measure against that definition uh
there's a constant privacy versus safety
trade-off that this industry is dealing
with at the same time that we're trying
to improve the privacy of users in doing
so we sometimes make it harder to keep
them safe and coming up with
technological solutions that allow you
to keep you safe without Gathering a
huge amount of data about them is one of
our big challenges
there's lots of issues between
information sharing between
organizations as well as the division of
responsibility with the government and
that's one of the constant challenges
we're dealing with we'll talk a lot
about this in the class is when you're
doing things like stopping terrorists or
stopping child molesters that feels like
a job the cops should be doing right if
it feels like hey don't we have people
that we pay for to enforce the laws but
as we'll talk about in the class it's
actually extremely complicated to and
effectively impossible for for law
enforcement to do this themselves you
know you have to help your users
directly and then work with law
enforcement in a way that is respectful
privacy in the law but also respectful
of the safety needs of your users
um and finally one of the interesting
emerging issues here is kind of the
fairness and the solutions because one
of the big uh things we do to solve the
scale issue is the use of machine
learning and machine learning has caused
all kinds of interesting issues and
we'll talk about much of those in the
class
thanks Alex that's uh that's really
interesting and I think it's a nice
especially number two there is a nice
segue into kind of the next question
that I'd have I do do want to comment we
might have already lost a lot of people
it's these challenges are big challenges
um yeah and I can you know I whenever I
read about these I think especially
about just five and six is just that the
complexity of working within an
organization working across
jurisdictions working within a
jurisdiction uh in terms of different
governments but in terms of building you
know the diversity of the group I mean
who are the people that that who might
be interested in taking this course who
are the people who would be served well
by this course and what are the jobs
that people who do this are are already
filling can you kind of give us an
example of the players of the scope of
of what's Happening Here yeah that's a
great question Pax um so one of the
great things about trusted safety is it
does attract people from a variety of
different disciplines and you need all
of those people to be firing on all
cylinders if you want to do a good job
uh you have research teams so you have
people who sometimes come from social
science backgrounds sociology
backgrounds Social Work backgrounds
um or they come from like data science
backgrounds whose job it is to think
about what are the abuse types how do we
measure them sometimes they do field
studies so they'll interview users
they'll interview victims of different
kinds of uh abuses and they'll come up
with ideas of how do we protect them uh
then you have product and Engineering
teams uh so the people who build the
product in the end are going to have to
be responsible for Designing good user
experiences building detection
mechanisms building features into the
system that keep people safe
um and then building the mechanisms on
the back end that help you find and stop
abuse such as the machine Learning
Systems um and kind of the the things
like content moderation pipelines and
such
you have people in operation so this is
actually a pretty broad field of folks
who come to this field form who often
come to trust and safety from a
different area they work in customer
service and customer support and they're
really interested in the safety
components and there's this is where
there's thousands of thousands of open
jobs in the industry right now
um is the people who take the policies
that come from high above and then
figure out how do these actually apply
to normal people uh build the pipelines
and then sort through billions and
billions of events or items of content
to try to decide how it works and then
build kind of a self-improvement process
to fix these things and then for the
absolute worst cases you you have
investigators
um so uh people whose job it is to
investigate the worst bad guys the worst
kind of abuses and then work with that
with law enforcement either because law
enforcement has come to the company or
because you're proactively going out to
refer the worst cases and they have a
really important job of understanding
like what is the worst kind of things
that are happening on our platform right
now so this is especially true for areas
is like fraud where you really need deep
investigations because fraudsters and
spam and spam senders are really
professional organizations and so
mapping out those orgs so you can take
care of them and then work with law
enforcement to perhaps bring some legal
pressure is important as well as areas
like counterterrorism and child safety
uh where the behavior of the people
online is something that you can't allow
at all um and you're dealing with
professional groups that you need to uh
sometimes counteract uh and in one
investigation you can sometimes have a
positive impact on hundreds or thousands
of victims of that one organization
that's great um can you you know it's
great to hear that you can have that big
an impact I mean I think that's one of
the benefits maybe of working in this
area can you elaborate a little bit is
so obviously at a larger organization
these may be there may be a specific
product in engineering that is focused
on trust and safety but I imagine this
class could be valuable if you're at a
startup if you're where you're not going
to have this big an Engineering Group if
you're if you're maybe you're not in
trust and safety you're not information
security but you're just a product
manager or you're just someone who runs
customer service would you still get
value I mean out of this class is this
still something that you want to be
thinking about yeah absolutely and and
that's a big goal of the class is to you
know we have we'll have about 180
students or so take the class in person
and I expect out of them based upon our
previous groups four or five of them
will go into full-time trust and safety
rules and that's great because part of
our goal is to just I think those five
per year would never have considered
these rules otherwise the other 175 are
going to be product managers and
engineers and data scientists
um doing other kinds of things but
there's very few products you can work
on where there's not some kind of safety
aspect right
um and so yes I totally agree that what
we part of what we want to do is for is
to help educate people who want to do
this as a career but also anybody who's
building these products it's important
for them to have the skill set that's
especially true for startups because
realistically a 12 startup is not going
to have a trust and safety team but they
will have a product manager and if that
product manager has in the back of their
head oh these are the safety issues I
learned about in that Stanford class
then maybe you won't make those mistakes
up front that make it so critical to
have a trust and safety team later maybe
you can kind of head a bunch of those
things off at the pass
maybe that's a good segue just kind of
in the next part of what we want to talk
about is just the class structure and I
know this changes a little bit from year
to year so if you could give us an
example of how do you approach teaching
this very difficult topic what is the
structure of the class actually look
like yeah it's a great question so
um this is an example structure again we
do update it year to year this is our
our current one as you can see we have
some tbds in here that we're still
working on
um general what we do is we have two
lectures a week each lecture is 80
minutes
um that will be in person first uh on
campus students and then we'll provide a
video via the scpd platform
um asynchronously so scpd students can
experience it asynchronously uh on their
own time
um we'll have a combination of lectures
that are broad so as you see here we
have a lecture on how do tech companies
work how do you design for trust and
safety right so that's kind of an
introduction to where to stress and
safety fit into organizations and what
are the different pieces
um we'll have a broad discussion
um of emerging issues for example but
the core of the class is looking at
specific domains of abuse understanding
the historical aspects here what are
some of the problems have been faced in
this area in the past and what are some
technical and operational and policy
solutions that come companies consider
in the future so our goal is not just to
say the world's terrible and make
everybody nihilistic and sad our goal is
to okay things are tough in this area
but it turns out in all of these areas
there are things you can do to address
the possible problems until we talk
about those Solutions and what might be
useful in different areas so you know
for example uh when we talk about uh you
know child uh sexual exploitation we
kind of talk about this is the space
this is how the bad things have happened
and then we talk about kind of the
positive side this is the ecosystem that
has grown up to deal with this these are
the kind of resources that are available
to companies and these are solutions
that have been put in place that have
demonstrated real benefits for children
who use these products and the ability
to keep bad guys off
um uh so you know it's both a historical
look and then we have several uh
lectures that really look forward
um especially like uh how our
blockchains and web 3 Technologies being
abused
um and uh how is end-end encryption
changing the trust and safety field uh
so you know a lot of review of the past
and then we talk a bit about these are
the areas that you have to think about
the future
so the structure of the class is uh
during the week we'll have those two
lectures there will be a discussion
section um and we'll have two different
options for scpd students to call in uh
via Zoom to participate in the
discussion sections um discussion
sections are optional uh this is like I
said before you get good at doing this
stuff by actually practicing it so we
don't want this to be a test based class
this is not a class where you get
homework every week and you have to do
problem sets
um and uh then take a big final what we
want to do is to give people the real
experience of students have given them
the real experience of dealing with
these issues so 30 of the class is based
upon quizzes that happen before each of
those lectures based upon the pre-reads
so for each class we'll have two or
three articles that we ask students to
read and then we have a pretty easy quiz
the quiz is just to make sure that
students and this is probably less the
scpd students and more of our in-person
Stanford students um to make sure
they're they do the pre-reads before the
lecture starts um and so my goal is for
everybody to get 100 of that on those uh
if they're just doing the pre-reads um
but then the vast majority of the grade
70 of it comes from a final project and
so the final project teams uh last year
uh the ratio here is we had three or
four computer science students and then
we had one political science student uh
who was taking a sister class that is
taught by Dr Shelby Grossman in the
political science department and those
four to five students worked together on
this final project where they they
decide on a very specific type of abuse
on a specific platform they study it
deeply and then they come up with a
technical and a policy a set of policy
solutions to deal with it
um so uh at the end of this the way this
is implemented is implemented as a bot
on Discord so we have a a class Discord
server and every group has its own two
channels and one of those channels is as
if it's the platform and the other
channels the control Channel and you
build a bot we give you a framework that
allows you to interact with Discord and
your team builds a bot that looks for
different kinds of abuse and then
reports this is what I've detected and
take certain steps so uh the other thing
you do is you put together a poster to
present this and then at the end of the
year we don't have the exact timing yet
that will be announced but at the end of
the year there is a three hour poster
session where the teams stand for their
poster uh and we have guest judges so
last year we had about 25 guest judges
from industry so these people who work
at Google and meta and Discord and
twitch and a variety of other Apple a
variety of other big companies who work
on trust and safety and those real
practitioners walk around they talk to
each team they they listen of the
presentation they look at their demo so
the students generally have a laptop
there to do a quick demo of their
product and they help give feedback and
to grade it and then one of the
interesting things the number of people
get jobs that way too as you can imagine
it's a pretty good way to interview for
a job for the scpd students they'll have
the option if if they happen to have the
ability to come Stanford they're welcome
to join us on campus
um otherwise we will be mixing the scpd
students in with the different student
groups so they can be a talking head on
a laptop to participate in that process
remotely if they're not able to get to
Canvas here's an example of one of the
posters from last year where they
specifically were studying
cryptocurrency fraud on Twitter and
built a entire normalization and machine
learning framework to look for different
kinds of frauds specifically around
cryptocurrency and have a lot of success
in doing so
that's really interesting so in terms of
the students taking this class this
class the the trust and safety
engineering there is an expectation that
you have some basic programming
background that you're able to to write
something that could interact with the
Discord API so on Stanford we'd say
that's at least through cs106b so it's
kind of a year of uh about a year or two
quarters of programming experience is
that a fair
right yeah we do expect students to have
basic programming experience you should
not take this class if you're just
learning a programming language for the
first time it's not you know different
students have different levels so we
have all the way up to you know fourth
year PhD students who are super
technical and deep into AI we have
students who have only taken who are
freshmen or sophomores who have only
taken the first couple of quarters
um so we do have mixes of groups uh we
try to mix up the groups by skill level
so that people can find different things
and there's a lot of work here other
than just programming but we do expect
everybody who takes the computer science
side to be able to participate in the
creation of the of the programming um
but there's a lot of parts in that uh
and it varies uh whether or not you're
building like a complex machine learning
or you're building say the interactive
component of the bot or the reporting
structure there's different there's
different levels here but yes we we
expect to have a basic programming
knowledge usually python is almost
always the language in which the
students choose to write the code in we
leave it open to them but we provide the
API in Python and most of the open
documentation on how to do the Discord
API is in Python so it is by far the
easiest language for most teams to
choose
yeah that makes sense and that that
actually uh that that sounds good
there's maybe even opportunity if you're
a beginning program or Advanced
programmer to to if you're Advanced
getting that that experience of coaching
someone through who's still learning
learning the nuts and bolts if you're
new is getting that experience maybe be
coached by another student uh who's
who's more advanced um yeah like these
incredible backgrounds right we'll have
a PhD student who's in who's in computer
vision and so they build a computer
vision nudity detection system from
scratch right like that is not the
expectation you know we try to normalize
the grading uh of these classes and you
know this is not we're not looking to
flunk anybody we're trying to we we have
grades to get people to do but there's
no curve here everybody can get an A if
everybody kind of fulfills uh the
requirements of the course you know
usually we have a distribution of A's
and B's and nobody gets below B unless
their team completely you know they
don't show up uh or their team
completely did you know missed uh uh you
know the outline of what they're
supposed to do um that's extremely rare
yeah you can scope the project to your
skill levels and it does sound like
there's an opportunity for for scpd for
any student who's a a working
professional who's maybe at one of these
companies already has the job to be able
to bring you know to to be able to bring
their professional experience you know
as you said one of your early lectures
is how does a tech company work well
you're going to know how the tech
company works because that's that's what
you're doing right now and you can bring
that experience and that knowledge to
the project as well yeah no that would
be great and we have a number of
students uh who take the class who are
we entry students or doing a master's
degree who have industry experience and
that is a great thing that I hope to get
from sapd students is the same kind of
real industry experience because like
you said these 19 year olds they're very
smart but they've never had the
realistic you know had to work on a
realistic project that has to ship on
time and have constraints um and that's
part of what we're trying to simulate
here by having it be a
multi-disciplinary project by having as
part of the project that you have to
simulate failures and think about how
your system fails
um it's a little bit different kind of a
standard computer science problem set
based project
that's great can we dig a little bit
deeper then into the learning goals of
the class and what what students will
get out of it or what you hope students
will get out of it at the end sure um so
the first learning goal is by the end of
this class we expect that any of our
students should be able to explain to
fellow software engineers and product
managers the common ways internet
Technologies are used to cause harm 10
weeks we're not expecting them to be the
world expert in trust and safety but if
one of our alumni is in an engineering
team and they say hey let's build an app
where you can send photos anonymously to
whoever you want on the internet they
can talk about oh these are three or
four things that have happened in the
past that isn't so good and so we should
think about when we build this product
the kinds of things that are likely to
happen
the second is as they work on these
issues that they understand how a lot of
these problems are really long existing
societal challenges uh you know hate
speech was not invented by the internet
discrimination was not invented by the
internet unfortunately child abuse was
not invented by the internet these are
all things that have existed for
thousands of years but the existence of
modern communication Technologies where
people can interact across the globe for
no cost and possibly speak to millions
of people at once definitely changes how
the societal challenges are reflected
and so a big part of our goal is to not
just say okay well this is how hate
speech happens but have kind of
understanding of how we got there and
what are the the legal and societal
guidelines that have existed in the past
that now need to be adopted to this new
world
oh the third is to just anticipate
safety risks for a proposed project
product so if somebody came to you with
like here's a product that you would
come up with like the basic risks for
that
um and practically uh we built we expect
them to be able at the end of this to
design and Implement a functional abuse
reporting flow uh powered by a basic
classifier this is not an AI class so
we're not going to go deep into how
classifiers work and such but the
expectation here is that any of these
teams have the ability to take a
framework that's provided to them
um and build a functional abuse
reporting flow that uses some kind of
intelligence behind it and and finally
and perhaps most importantly one of the
things we're trying to do is we're
trying to build empathy for the people
who actually get harmed
um when products get built this is a
screenshot of a young woman named Amanda
Todd
um who famously took her own life after
being bullied online
um her death in the the work her parents
have done since she passed away has
really changed the way lots of tech
companies thought about safety and one
thing we want to do here is for these
students to be able to learn from these
tragedies of the past to have empathy
for the people who use these products so
that they don't have to learn the hard
way through tragedy of what possibly can
happen and understanding like this is
what's happened before these are the
mistakes that were made so that you can
perhaps make different and less uh
horrible mistakes in the future uh when
products are built
one thing we do have to talk about with
this class is this class does deal with
a lot of difficult content right so we
will we're going to have a lecture on
hate speech and we're going to talk
about hate speech and people will be
exposed to bad words and slurs and the
ways people have used hate speech in the
past to abuse others we're going to talk
about sexual exploitation about children
and adults we're going to talk about
suicide self-harm and uh both in the
in-person class and the scpd students we
we recognize that different people are
going to bring different personal
histories to dealing with these issues
and for some people some of these issues
might just be too close to home for them
to be able to deal with and so the way
we deal with this is
um you know our syllabus uh will be
published uh it it it's going to be
linked from this video you can see when
we're going to have certain lectures
um and if you look at this topic you're
like oh man this is something that might
be hard for me you can consider skipping
it you consider trying trying it out in
the video version but then bailing out
um and and if you don't want to do the
pre-reads or something this is something
where we're just gonna have some
flexibility students can reach out to me
and say Hey you know this suicide topic
it's I I had a tragedy in my family in
the last year it's too early for me to
engage on this I'd like to do something
alternative
um and we'll provide you with you know
an alternative reading on a totally
different topic um instead of having to
do it so uh you know basically what we
want to say is one this is a hard class
um and people should not you know it is
not a Sunshine In Rainbows class as you
can imagine right we're talking about
really difficult things
um but we're not doing so to try to make
people feel uncomfortable or to insult
them or make them angry we're doing so
because the truth is is to deal with
these issues you have to get your hands
dirty and you have to understand what's
actually going on
um and so people should take the class
if they feel like they can do that
um and they're uh you know they feel
like they engage with most of the topics
and if there's say one topic that that
is out of bounds for you then we will
have that flexibility to make sure uh
that everybody can experience the rest
of the class without that one topic
discouraging them and they won't be
punished from a grading perspective also
each team comes up with their their
topic and so for teams where they have
people who have maybe faced some of
these really difficult issues those are
sometimes the teams that will choose
something like fraud or a Bitcoin scam
or spam which are the kinds of topics
that aren't as uh emotionally difficult
for people
um so if anybody has any questions about
the class uh they can hit me up at
Stamos stanford.edu and I'm really
looking forward to this quarter and to
having the scpe students be part of the
experience
thanks Alex that was wonderful I do want
to just and I know we ended on the very
uh the the the the seriousness of the
class and the subject matter but I do
want to emphasize again as you mentioned
earlier that there is doing this allows
you potentially have a big impact in
terms of making better products that are
safer that are that that prove the goal
is to prevent this kind of abuse and
harm from happening in the future so
yeah absolutely it has a the potential
here is is really big in terms of having
a positive it's a very rewarding career
right because you really you know
there's people who spend their lives
optimizing ad networks or building
online games and that's fine but there's
nothing quite like helping real people
and knowing that there's real people who
something bad was happening to them and
and you stopped it that's a pretty
rewarding feeling and uh and so for for
the folks who are in a position to do it
I I do recommend it as an area they
should study and like you said before
it's also just something you should keep
in mind if you're going to be an
entrepreneur if you're gonna be a
product manager at a startup then be you
know being the person on your team who
has this background and can do this work
is also makes you very very valuable to
them
right
well thank you again Alex for for
joining us today and talking about this
and we look forward to seeing some of
you in the class
thanks